okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about triangles and specifically
isosceles triangles equilateral
triangles and just triangles in general
so this is something they test on the
act they want you to have a rudimentary
understanding of so let's get right into
this lesson so the first thing i wanted
to just show you is uh an isosceles
triangle what's an isosceles triangle
it's a triangle where two of the sides
are congruent meaning they're the same
length and so that's what i denoted by
these little marks to show that these
two sides are the same now what that
means though is that if it's isosceles
if you look at the angles that are
across from those
congruent sides those are called the
base angles and those will also be
congruent to each other and vice versa
if you have two of these base angles
congruent if you look at the sides that
are across from those base angles those
sides will
also be congruent now if it's an
equiangular triangle meaning all these
angles are equal
which means that all the angles in a
triangle they always add up to 180
degrees right that's important to
remember but if they're all equal that
means that all these angles are going to
be 60 degrees 60 60 60 right but if it's
equiangular that means that it will also
be equilateral meaning all the sides are
going to be equal and vice versa if it's
equilateral then you know it's
equiangular all these angles are going
to be equal they're all going to be 60.
so just remember that all the angles add
up to 180 degrees in a triangle and then
if it's isosceles
the base angles are congruent and vice
versa so let's get right into this
example see if you can pause the video
see if you can do this one on your own
and we'll go through it
okay so basically we're trying to find
the measure of angle cef so where's cef
c e f that's this angle right here now
notice that they're telling us that
these two sides are congruent so that
means that if we go across from those
sides those are the base angles right
there and those are going to be
congruent
now we know that they're the same so i'm
just going to call them x so x plus x
plus 70
x plus x plus 70 equals 180 degrees
right
so this is 2x plus 70.
if i subtract 70 from both sides i get
110 and if i divide both sides by 2
x comes out to 55 degrees so these are
both going to be 55. now i'm just going
to write that in here 55 and that's what
i recommend is when you do these types
of geometry problems go ahead and write
right on the diagram because you might
need to know
that angle or that segment for another
you know the next step
now notice how these form a straight
line these two angles those are called a
linear pair but the main thing to
realize is that they add up to 180
degrees that's like a straight angle so
if this is 55 this angle here must be
125
so that's it that's the measure of angle
cef 125 degrees and you got it